welcome back nascar takes over las vegas
this weekend and the las vegas motor
speedway who is sponsoring this next
segment has a host of activities taking
place i went out to the track to get
more details
it is a big week in las vegas it is race
week when this is the biggest week of
the year for you is it not jeff well one
of two we have two nascar races we got
another one in october but it's
certainly one of the two so what is
going on what's the preparation right
now like for you well it's early part of
the week so right now we're getting the
track ready and everything from painting
to making sure all the seats are cleaned
off you know that we're ready for
everybody to come in the rv's start
arriving on wednesday hauler parade is
on thursday you get race cars on the
track on friday what is something people
watching the race that they're maybe not
a diehard nascar fan what is something
they should be looking for come race day
i tell you it's something i compare to
hockey you have to go and experience it
to to really believe it when you go to a
hockey game and see how fast they skate
and how fast the puck moves you cannot
see that on television it's the same way
coming to a car race you watch it on
television and they're all running the
same speed but when that same speed is
180 miles per hour and they go past you
you get a true appreciation of speed how
many fans are gonna have here this
weekend well hopefully we'll have a
crowd somewhere upwards of 75 000 here
on sunday for the pennzoil 400 and we'll
also have races on friday and saturday
as well truck series friday night vanity
series on saturday afternoon and in this
area we're in is this pit road you're on
pit road so this is where they're going
to be changing their tires getting fuel
making adjustments repairs to the car
hopefully those pit stops are no more
than 11 or 12 seconds and then they call
booty down the pit road and get back in
the race they come down here we're doing
four tire changes gas enough and they're
doing that in 11 seconds well if you
don't have to put fuel in we can do it
in about six seconds we can change more
tires in about six seconds they have to
wait on the fuel so it's going to take
about 11 to 12 to make a full pit stop
if your car is empty yeah this is
incredible we're between turn one and
turn two how steep of a bank is this
well we've got 20 degrees of banking
right here it actually starts at 20
degrees progresses all the way up to 22
degrees at the top you're probably about
the equivalent of a three-story building
by the time you get up there this is so
high yeah that's 22 degrees of banking
you're probably at least two and a half
three stories up if you try to build a
building here wow now when the cars come
around turn one into turn two how fast
are they going probably going to carry
somewhere a little over 200 miles per
hour into turn one that's going to be
the top speed now an average speed for a
lap here track record like 190 293 but
that's an average speed because they'll
get a little slower as they get through
the turn but when they're coming through
turn one getting into this
close to 200 maybe a little more now how
many cars start the race on sunday we'll
have 40 cars starting on sunday if
that's a full field now if there's 36
teams that are guaranteed in the race
but we could have up to 40. we can get
two cars wide three parks wide they can
go four wide if they're really brave
they're really brave they go four wide
but you'll see a lot of three wide here
on the restart it's going to be an
incredible weekend out here at the
racetrack before we go do you know who's
going to be doing the national anthem or
any opening ceremony uh yeah midland is
going to be our pre-race concert on
sunday really excited to have them there
for a number of grammys in fact they're
going to be up for acm awards on monday
night over allegiant stadium tierra
kennedy up and coming big machine
artists that's gonna be doing the
national anthem so it'll be a nice
little country music feel to our
pre-race it's gonna be a great weekend
and you've got a very busy week ahead of
you jess we'll let you go thank you my
friend